I certainly hope you dance as well as
you dress
there's only one way to find out
[Music]
you and I we're not so different agent
Argyle
little help hold on
[Music]
the book is phenomenal sweetie but
what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother Ellie it's called a
cop-out
whoa hey there's a cat in there
oh my God you're Ellie freaking Conway
oh yeah what is it you do
would you sign my book
here we go
I love this book
[Music]
come on
who are these people real life spies why
would they care about me because you're
a goddamn fortune teller really
when you wrote in your new book actually
happened and you Kicked the Hornets Nest
you didn't even know existed I'm in some
really big trouble mom
I want all assets on them now I need her
to write the next chapter
God I can't
[Music]
it's time for you to meet the real agent
Argyle
oh my God oh my God oh my God
foreign foreign